what's going on there people we got
ourselves another resident evil movie
but this one's different capcom worked
hand in hand with the director on this
one i'm here it's harkening back to the
first two resident evil games which is
what i'm really excited to hear
i don't know how you guys are feeling
let's see what's going on we've been
waiting for this a long time
[Music]
every story has a beginning
mess up any trailer lines
discover the origin of evil
yes best opening trailer dialogue
you conspiracies weren't true when we
were kids they're not true now
we need to expose umbrella
watch this
i'm afraid claire i'm afraid of what
they're gonna do to this town
you see an umbrella they have an
incident
raccoon police
[Music]
let the world know what's really going
on are a lot of images that are
harkening back yeah
a lot of characters too yeah
wow actual game characters
[Music]
yeah you do
shall we go
see leon he's leon yeah
chris claire leon
wesker
i love that actor
they're
[Laughter]
as i take on umbrella corporations
the mansion
the buckley hills
[Music]
you're not supposed to scream
you know the rules that's a very vocal
bunch very vocal bunch right there
not bad i think it looks like a major
step up from what we got before
yeah i mean it looks like it actually
cares to resemble the games it's based
on i played resident evil one and two
ages ago barely remember it but one
thing i've always wanted to see be
brought to life is them getting involved
with the actual mansion i think i heard
this not long i've been actually this
morning
i heard is that they actually use the
blueprints from the resident evil
mansion from the first game when working
with capcom in order to make sure when
they recreate the mansion and bring it
to life so it looks like with their
budget they were able to put it in some
places
like with some of the zombie effects
also with some of the creatures and then
of course the production design but then
some of the cgi looks a little bit kind
of like the sci-fi channel yeah
i feel like this movie is in an odd
position for that because especially
with some of the early on dialogue i'm
like okay some of this does look kind of
cheesy in the way like the early
resident evil game cut scenes were sort
of cheesy where it's like a little bit
hammy in the acting and stuff like that
but i am excited for you them actually
embracing the sort of survival horror
spirit not going full-on like crazy
sci-fi action with it because that's
part of the games but the earlier ones
up until you know you get to like part
six are more about suspense and the
elegance and the conditions and yeah
just like seeing the inside of the
mansion it got me nostalgic uh because
yeah you can kind of tell that that tlc
is there and it feels like raccoon city
it feels like the barclay mountains and
stuff like that and yeah you've got you
know the dogs and the liquors that
classic white zombie turning around
while he's eating that's a classic shot
yeah that's a classic classic
shot of resident evil yeah yeah and it's
been remade in the remakes of the games
and stuff like that so yeah as somebody
who like had fun with paul w s
anderson's movies but has been craving
the actual faithful take i hope this is
good i still feel like it could wind up
being kind of cheesy but it looks like
it is trying kind of very cheesy already
but it looks like it's at least gonna
deliver on the kind of cheese that's
appropriate for resident evil yeah it
looks like an entertaining horror action
movie yeah which is a genre that i don't
think the resident evil movies prior set
out to achieve which was actually the
horror angle to it and they never seem
to really care to be a horror movie
maybe the first one sort of i ultimately
fell off the franchise i didn't catch
like the last two i think i'm liking
more of like the gritty look to it you
could feel some of like the filmmaking
inspirations tonally this is just the
first trailer so we don't know tonally
exactly what it's going to be like now
there are parts of it where i could see
that he might take some like romero
influences in here in terms of the tone
it looks like they're actually trying to
make the zombies genuinely scary it
looks like they're actually going to try
to scare you and make this intense
versus cheesy pulpy sci-fi action which
is something i just wasn't a fan of and
then here it's like yeah could the
acting be a little bit better maybe but
it also could be trailer dialogue i'm
going to give it the benefit of the
doubt i'm a lot more forgiving when it
comes to trailers and the actual movie
going experience that's why they're
combining the first two yeah i mean yeah
definitely it does because there's
enough that's something i'm curious
about because there's enough story in
both of those games to fill a movie yeah
but at the same time especially having
had a franchise that has included
game characters and aspects before i
guess i could see why they would want to
maybe do both and then you also get a
city suburb sort of setting as well as
your far removed mountain mansion you
know haunted gothic vibe as well and
then you've got you know stars and the
umbrella corp and all that i get why
they would want to incorporate both
because especially when you're trapped
in the police station there's a
different more action-y vibe i think too
that comes out of that with resident
evil 2. well that's what i mean is i i
could also see there being perhaps some
john carpenter vibes being thrown into
here too why i'm being a little bit more
like optimistic towards this is because
the intent feels very much on display
here at least get the impression
whoever's behind this one sorry for not
knowing but just guided 47 meters down
awesome
at least the impression that i'm getting
from the trailer alone is that whoever
that guy is he actually
likes the game or cares to honor the
game and visually represent it in more
ways than one it has that impression of
a guy going back to the early games that
he played instead of trying to do like
the later ones
and uh you know i just i kind of feel
like i should just give it a chance
we'll see you know this is very clear
focused uh not so much chris or leon
claire looks like she's really the main
character of this yeah yeah and is that
i think that's robium is that robbie and
that is ravi
chris redfield robbie mill yeah
dude well and maybe they're gonna bring
in some code veronica stuff with that
too because that's the game over your
real thing who is the code veronica
reference right yeah one and that game
you follow claire for a whole lot of it
before like switching to chris yeah your
boy's playing albert wesker right yeah i
think so how do they get a nice i don't
remember their character names
i remember just the main names but guys
what'd you think about this trailer are
you in the camp that is for it or
against it leave your thoughts down
below once you subscribe and click that
bell and hit that like button hey let's
do a
daniel gallacher you're our only hope
because if there's one thing that
resident evil games and i assume this
movie are going to be very notorious for
it's being resourceful with your
resources and what do you need you need
health packs man you need medicine
because you're getting bites you're
getting cuts you're getting nicks we
need those green herbs my friend or the
red herbs you mix them together which
i'm sure you could do because you are an
apothecast you are somebody who works
with the healing chemicals of life and
if there's anyone you need on your team
in a zombie apocalypse it's a medic it's
a health person so you're the berry
actually i don't think that's what barry
did for the team in resident evil one
but either way you know he's got kind of
a scottish look so it works
either way hope you're doing well buddy
and stay healthy out there much love
restart
[Music]